hola buenos días
me podrían confirmar si ya ven mi
pantalla en el chat
se infectó gracias
muy buenos días mi nombre es a link y
bueno hicimos esta sesión de preguntas y
respuestas específicamente del
campeonato queremos el objetivo de esta
sesión es ayudarlos para con aquellos
profesores que aún no se registran y
repasar un poquito lo que se ha visto en
ocasiones anteriores respecto a este
campeonato y sobre todo resolver las
dudas que tengan para que todos puedan
tener un registro exitoso y puedan
puedan participar
muy bien
la presentación la van a encontrar en la
siguiente liga y en un ratito más la
ponemos también en el chat para que la
puedan descargar ver y la puedan
resolver regresar otra vez si tienen
alguna duda
ok el programa de capacitación que
tenemos es bien sencillo que ustedes se
puedan registrar y les puede también
funcionar mucho solo tienen que llenar
un formulario con su correo de khan
academy para recibir también el
reconocimiento al esfuerzo al tiempo que
están invirtiendo ustedes y toda la
información del programa la liga es es
la que está en pantalla y también hay un
documento con toda la información del
programa no ahí se se añade información
y también está la liga de este programa
christine y no sé si quiera se esté
mencionar un poquito más de lo que es el
programa de capacitación de khan academy
sí hola soy christine la gerente del
mercado de khan academy aqui en mexico y
tenemos muchos docentes participando en
esta este programa de capacitación
que dura seis meses donde van a recibir
reconocimiento para su esfuerzo y pues
todos tienen que llenar el formulario
cuenta su correo que estás usando con su
cuenta de khan academy eso es lo más
importante porque es la única manera de
recibir una información si has inscrito
con otro correo van a recibir un correo
esta semana
pidiendo su correo de khan academy
entonces uno de los objetivos de este
programa es apoyarles a este regreso a
clases y año escolar con su uso de khan
academy y tienen que tenemos el proyecto
el campeonato que estamos lanzando al
nivel nacional por primera vez en méxico
entonces en módulo 2 tienen que
inscribirse en el campeonato para
recibir su reconocimiento y es muy fácil
inscribirse pero a la mayoría de ustedes
todavía tiene que hacer eso y pues
esta capacitación vuelven a resonar será
oportunidad
a preguntar y también aprender más de
cómo funciona este vector y pues si hay
preguntas estamos también viendo el chat
y pues gracias por venir y estamos aquí
para apoyarles
muy bien
bueno el reto de khan academy empezó el
10 de septiembre no sé cuántos de
ustedes profesores ya se inscribieron
sin embargo aunque ya haya empezado el
10 de septiembre todavía podemos
registrarnos todavía todos ustedes
pueden hacer clic en el banner que les
aparece en su en su sesión de khan
academy se los voy a mostrar al iniciar
sesión como profesores y aún ustedes no
se han registrado les debe de aparecer
un banner donde les dice que ya empezó
el campeonato y todavía pueden
registrarse por favor este háganlo
aunque haya empezado el 10 de septiembre
este campeonato dura 10 semanas
terminamos hasta el 16 de noviembre y es
bien importante recordarles que ustedes
no compiten contra otras escuelas así
que lo pueden ir haciendo a su ritmo se
pueden registrar a partir de este
momento y empezar este con este
campeonato no como dice christine es la
primera vez que se hace en méxico a
nivel nacional así que hay que
motivarnos todos para poder este
levantarlo y
en nombre de méxico así super super bien
no voy a regresarme a la presentación
si tienen dudas por favor en el chat con
gusto los atendemos
ok que tenemos que hacer para participar
en el campeonato es súper fácil crear
una cuenta en khan academy que yo sé que
todos ustedes ya tienen una cuenta en
khan academy que ya han tenido sesiones
anteriormente de cómo de cómo hacerlas
si alguien todavía tiene dudas con gusto
en el chat lo podemos ayudar con una
guía de cómo registrarse vale para poder
participar en este campeonato que
necesitamos agregar crear la clase
primero que nada agregar 10 alumnos y
agregar contenido muy bien es importante
recordarles profes que hay que eliminar
las clases que no estamos utilizando
todas las clases inactivas que tengamos
hay que borrarlas una vez que ustedes se
registran al campeonato en automático
nos toma todas las clases que tenemos en
nuestra plataforma entonces es
importante que todas las clases que
están inactivas las quitemos para que
sólo participemos con aquellas clases
nuevas que queremos usar en este
campeonato no agregar a nuestros 10
estudiantes como mínimo no es un máximo
podemos agregar
asignar tres recursos por semana durante
las semanas del campeonato aquí estos
tres recursos
es importante mencionar los que son como
30 minutos los que estarían practicando
los alumnos realmente no es tanto tiempo
el que les van a invertir sin embargo
los alumnos al estar practicando con
estos ejercicios se motivan porque
pueden ellos insólitos celebrando todos
sus logros y acaban practicando mucho
más tiempo no se hace muy muy dinámico
para ellos les gusta y le invierten más
tiempo lo cual a ustedes les ayuda a
llegar a su objetivo no que es que los
diez alumnos los mínimo diez alumnos
cumplan con el 100% de todos sus
recursos
pueden ir revisando el tablero de
control para ver el progreso que van
teniendo sus alumnos y otra cosa que
podemos hacer es motivar a los alumnos y
celebrar los logros de su esfuerzo no
ahí podemos hacer diferentes cosas para
para motivarlos a mí se me ocurre no sé
en alguna ceremonia que hacemos los días
lunes al alumno que siempre está
terminando antes todos sus recursos
entregarle alguna medalla algún
reconocimiento algo significativo para
que ellos se motiven y éste empujen
también a los otros compañeros que de
repente no no quieren avanzar no
muy bien como les comentaba este bueno
ya ya inicio el campeonato termina el 16
de noviembre pueden participar cualquier
estudiante de la republica mexicana
desde primaria hasta bachillerato el
campeonato está pensado para motivar a
los estudiantes sin importar su nivel y
el programa se adapta fácilmente a todo
tipo de aula horario o ambiente escolar
aquí ustedes van a ir avanzando a su
ritmo vale
como pueden participar los profesores
bueno los profesores deben agregar sus
clases en khan academy y revisar el
contenido que desean asignar a sus
estudiantes recuerden que es súper fácil
este agregar una clase y agregar
contenidos y yo le agregue nose 23
recursos
puedo ir modificarlo y agregar cuanto
más contenido yo considere necesario
para llevar a cabo con el objetivo de mi
clase
los profesores usan las herramientas de
khan academy para asignar actividades y
practican de manera personalizada a su
clase ustedes van asignando estas
actividades y pueden ir practicando con
los alumnos ya sean salón de clases ya
sea que ellos avancen de manera
individual
finalmente el profesor recibirá datos e
información sobre cada estudiante y su
progreso para apoyar su aprendizaje nos
generan reportes estos reportes nos
muestran el logro que va teniendo cada
uno de nuestros estudiantes y es muy
útil para nosotros porque podemos ir
viendo cómo van avanzando cada alumno es
diferente cada uno va avanzando a su
ritmo y bueno ahí podemos ir dándonos
cuenta de cómo va el salón
cómo puedo participar si yo soy un
alumno los estudiantes van completando
sus ejercicios de cualquier materia a su
ritmo realizan las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento para ganar
puntos en especial ganan unas medallas
de edición limitada estos estos premios
son digitales y aunque bueno algunos de
ustedes seguro ya los vivieron pero los
niños se emocionan mucho no al momento
de darle al botoncito de celebrar les da
les da mucho gusto los motiva a seguir
haciendo otros otros ejercicios
la clase entera podrá ver el progreso
que tienen a través de un tablero que va
marcando cada momento y las metas que se
están alcanzando la clase celebra al
descargar los premios una vez que
alcanzan las metas ganando así estos
premios digitales que les mencionaba y
las escuelas que alcanzan más metas
recibirán un paquete sorpresa de canacar
en les repito no es que ustedes están
compitiendo con otro colegio simplemente
al ser un usted es una de las escuelas
que alcanzaron más metas van a recibir
una de estas sorpresas de khan academy
vamos viendo hasta aquí christina y algo
que quieras este agregar
pero si hay preguntas por favor tenemos
dudas este en el chat las podemos ir
contestando
ok
[Música]
muy bien
ok bueno para entrar es el punto khan
academy punto org ahí pueden ingresar
voy a ingresar ahorita como
incógnito para qué
aquellos que no se han registrado bueno
es súper fácil
ustedes se iniciarían como maestros no
nosotros como profesores vamos a iniciar
aquí que esto yo sé que ya lo hicieron
en alguna sesión anterior simplemente es
por si hay algún profesor que nos
acompaña por primera vez entonces
nosotros yo les recomiendo que se
registren siempre con su correo
electrónico algunas veces dejamos de
usar nuestro cuenta en facebook o en la
cuenta de google entonces nos
registramos con el correo electrónico
sólo nos pide nuestro correo
nombre y apellido y bueno una contraseña
ya saben de 8 caracteres
que sea fácil de recordar para nosotros
no nos registramos
y bueno al momento de que ustedes se
entren van a ver su cuenta así tal vez
ahorita no tienen clases o muchos de
ustedes y lo primero que van a ver en
grande va a ser el banner el banner para
que se porte se registren al campeonato
no aquí por ejemplo a mí me dice ya
empezó el campeonato no te has
registrado pero primero para poderme
registrar en el campeonato necesito
agregar al menos a 10 estudiantes
entonces es súper fácil le dan en
agregar a estudiantes y agregan a los
estudiantes como los pueden agregar
bueno podemos mostrarles este código que
recomendamos es lo más lo más fácil al
momento de que tenemos a todos los
alumnos en el salón de clases mostrarles
ese código para que se registren ya que
si lo mandamos por correo electrónico
muchas veces no leen el correo
electrónico entonces no hay otra manera
no lo más sencillo es mostrarles el
código para que se registren a nuestra
clase y de esta manera podamos
participar
aquí yo ya tengo dos clases creadas
recuerden si alguna de estas clases
nosotros ya no la utilizamos la
eliminamos para que no nos afecte
desde configuración
eliminar esta clase así de sencillo la
eliminamos y solo voy a entrar al
campeonato con mi clase de biología
pero para poder entrar a este campeonato
bueno tengo que agregar a mis diez
estudiantes alguna duda hasta aquí que
nos quieran compartir en el chat
cuántas tareas se requiere por alumnos
pregunta esta línea bueno se recomienda
que se hagan tres se asignen tres
recursos a la semana para que de esta
manera éste puedas cumplir ahora estos
tres recursos en los tienes que asignar
a todos los estudiantes a los
estudiantes que tienes en esta clase
en la tarea de mentalidad de crecimiento
está la puedes agregar una vez la puedes
mandar también asignar la una vez a la
semana
y estoy combatiendo la vida para el
contenido que tenemos para bachillerato
también tenemos contenido para la
primaria pero no voy a compartir la liga
y si pueden
a ver cómo funciona esta parte la
mentalidad de crecimiento es muy
importante en este directo y no sé si
quieres explicar un poco más de eso aquí
ok
bueno los ejercicios de mentalidad de
crecimiento tienen niveles de éxito más
altos que aquellos con una mentalidad
fija enseñarle a los alumnos acerca de
este concepto tiene el potencial de
hacerlos mucho más positivos más
perseverantes y más exitosos en khan
academy podemos reforzar una mentalidad
de crecimiento de varias maneras
crearon creamos dentro de la plataforma
un currículum que está dirigido
especialmente a primaria secundaria y
bachillerato si se incluyeron incluso
testimonios de algunos estudiantes y se
crearon vídeos para poderles explicar
cómo funciona el cerebro y solo y sobre
todo la importancia de imponernos metas
para poder lograr estos objetivos hay
varias actividades también de primaria y
secundaria son lecciones y ahorita les
va a compartir christine la liga para el
bachillerato
ok que debemos hacer para promover una
mentalidad de crecimiento en mis alumnos
asignar las actividades semanales de
mentalidad de crecimiento que se
encuentran en tus clases compartir las
experiencias y sobre todo tu experiencia
personal de fallar al principio y
perseverar para ser exitoso por ejemplo
un quien de ustedes tenía problemas con
alguna materia en específico o no
álgebra que son las más este siempre las
más difíciles bueno a una una de éstas
podría ser que nosotros como profesores
nos pongamos ese reto de tomar toda la
unidad de álgebra y ver cómo para
poderles nosotros transmitir a nuestros
estudiantes cómo fue nuestra experiencia
no como empecé no sabiendo nada de
álgebra y cómo fui avanzando durante las
unidades ahí al final pues éste obtener
alguna medalla algún premio esa sería
alguna experiencia que les podríamos
compartir a nuestros estudiantes para
motivarlos también no
alguna duda hasta aquí con la de las
materias de mentalidad de crecimiento
ya les compartió christine la liga
sí sí sí sí pero no hay dudas pero
podemos esperar dos segundos más a ver
y nos dice la vigilia que al principio
les mostró mucha preocupación a sus
alumnos y al final están muy emocionados
si la verdad es que es justamente eso lo
que acabamos de comentar primero nos
estresamos un poquito nos frustramos
pero al ver que la verdad es bastante
simple bastante práctica la plataforma
te va llevando entonces es muy
emocionante y les estén estamos
generando mucha curiosidad a los alumnos
en algo que es este para ellos muy
atractivo y eso también los motiva mucho
emocionalmente
ok
bueno en la pantalla les estoy mostrando
la página de soporte técnico de khan
academy aquí pueden encontrarlas las
respuestas a las preguntas más comunes
que nos hacen y recibir todo el apoyo
que necesitan no nada más
se los compartimos también en el chat
y viene dividido en categorías errores y
soluciones de problemas las preguntas
frecuentes y también pregunta la
comunidad
y tengo a paola que nos dice
que no entendió mis paola que es lo que
no está entendiendo si nos puede
especificar un poquito más la pregunta y
con gusto le ayudamos
en esta página ustedes van a poder
encontrar las preguntas más frecuentes
respecto al problema que tengan si no
logran encontrar la pregunta al final de
la presentación están todos los correos
donde también se pueden contactar con
nosotros y los podemos apoyar
ok me el profesor pedro nos pregunta se
compite de manera interna en cada campo
exacto profesor bueno se compite de
manera interna
no hay competencia con otros equipos de
otros planteles no la hay tampoco hay
competencia de usted con otro grupo o
sea es una competencia que ustedes están
haciendo
con sus alumnos nada más de manera
interna en el salón para ir alcanzando
metas y objetivos no van a competir con
otros planteles ni con otros estados es
de manera interna
ahora solo
ok misil ya me dice que se le dificulta
un poco como agregarlas introducirlas si
de hecho ustedes tienen que agregar
mínimo tres actividades a la semana y
pueden practicarlas en el aula para que
se les vaya haciendo más fácil
estoy trabajando emprendimiento con mis
estudiantes también
es un reto
a 200 que están enseñando matemáticas y
ciencias pero si hay contenido
podrías participar también
contenido relevante no
ok al misma ola ya quedó esté claro el
profesor pedro igual
a la competencia la van a hacer ustedes
mismos no van a irse forzando ustedes
mismos a lograr sus metas sus objetivos
que tengan en su clase para que todos
ustedes vayan avanzando a su propio
ritmo
ok les voy a mostrar el tablero de
control que es el que ustedes seguro
algunos ya pueden ver
bien
este es el tablero de control aquí nos
va a ir mostrando el nivel que van
teniendo los alumnos cuántos niveles son
los que ustedes quieran anteriormente me
parece que estaban limitados ahorita
ustedes pueden ir haciendo los niveles
que ustedes consideren no entre más
ejercicios hagan más prácticas pues más
niveles van a alcanzar recuerden que
para aquellos este
clases que tengan más niveles y más
clases completadas se les va a hacer
llegar un reconocimiento
muy bien
perfecto gracias mis ros alguna otra
duda algunos de ustedes ya vio el
progreso ya lo está utilizando en el
salón de clases
christina ya compartiste la liga de
mentalidad de crecimiento para
bachillerato la podrías volver
de nuevo
muy bien
ok cómo podemos utilizar el campeonato
con nuestros alumnos
para tener éxito los alumnos en el
campeonato tienen que completar los
ejercicios que ustedes están enviando no
ellos los pueden hacer a su propio ritmo
pero los tienen que completar realizar
las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento para ganar puntos y en
especial estas medallas de edición
limitada revisar periódicamente su
progreso a través del tablero que les
mostraba que ya tiene marcados los
momentos clave las metas alcanzadas y
celebrar los premios una vez que
alcanzan sus metas lo que les decía es
importante celebrar les los premios para
motivarlos ya sea desde que se ganó una
paleta o mencionamos al alumno se
levanta y todos le aplaudimos de alguna
manera este motivarlos no para que así
tanto este alumno siga creciendo y
también los otros alumnos se inspiren
dice y lo acompañan
alguna a ver si hay más dudas
ok
gracias cristina ya les comparte o
christina él
el material de bachillerato
y bueno acá tenemos otras preguntas de
otros profesores que no les aparecen las
actividades que ya hicieron les aparecen
en blanco
porque tienen que mandar un correo a
nuestro soporte típico en español
jobs yo voy a compartir la liga pero eso
es algo
muy importante para nosotros
y puedes saber entonces voy a compartir
la vida y tienes que escribir un correo
a nuestro equipo de soporte
también aquí en la página que les puse
hace un momento están las categorías
donde pueden checar algunas de las
preguntas frecuentes ahí vienen todos
estos temas también no igual puedes
escribirlo como dice cristina o buscarlo
también en la en la página de soporte
porque también había otra pregunta si no
me equivoco que al parecer les mando las
la clase
no pueden ver las tareas les di el
código y aún no mis letizia si también
nos hace favor de escribir a soporte
para ver qué puede estar pasando con su
clase
gracias
alguna otra pregunta o duda
recuerden que esta sesión está pensada
para resolver todas las dudas que
ustedes tengan y se puedan inscribir al
campeonato
alguien que ya esté participando que
tenga alguna duda antes de pasar a la
parte de ganarse un kit para su clase
las certificaciones bueno se da un
reconocimiento no son certificaciones y
si son reconocimientos hay
reconocimientos también para el
campeonato pero si estás hablando de el
programa de capacitación en la próxima
semana los docentes que han terminado
los requisitos para módulo 12 van a
recibir sus certificados entonces por
eso es muy importante que todos los
docentes que están participando están
usando su colegio de canacar a mí y
están leyendo el documento del programa
donde está la información
gracias christina
comentar mis rose christine que en los
primeros mensajes comentaron que eran
aunque es un reconocimiento
muy bien
ok que contienen estos kits que les va a
enviar khan academy y cómo pueden
ganarlos a ustedes como profesores uno
se les va a enviar a aquellos profesores
stickers del programa pósters de
mentalidad de crecimiento y unos lápices
personalizados de khan academy estos son
unos unas imágenes de prueba perdón de
de muestra son diferentes stickers hay
diferentes imágenes y bueno como ustedes
pueden ganar uno de estos kits
pues
tienen que inscribirse esta semana al
campeonato y el equipo que está
manejando el campeonato va
a elegir ganadores entonces también para
las personas que están participando la
programa de capacitación vamos a tener
otras oportunidades de ganar a un xerez
para su clase y voy a mandar correos con
más información pero a es algo que
pienso que es muy divertido y una manera
de
generando para para citar unos también
muy bien ok bueno vamos a hacer
dicen
ok y christina nos preguntamos en qué
tiempo llegaba en el nivel cuatro y
medio él reconocimos estar platicando
del campeonato o del programa de
capacitación que estás platicando
del campeonato
no
ok mientras la la profesor ros o la
profesora arroz nos contesta quién de
ustedes me puede compartir en el chat
que debe de hacer como profesor para
tener éxito éxito en el campeonato lo
mencionamos al principio cuántos alumnos
necesito tener mínimo cuántos recursos
debo de asignar por semana
quien nos puede decir para hacerle una
ovación aquí en esta sesión para
motivarlos también a ustedes cuando
iniciamos la sesión lo dijimos el mínimo
de estudiantes 10 muy bien profesor
pedro muchas gracias y tres recursos
perfecto profesor de que el plantel es
usted
entonces necesitamos tener mínimo 10
estudiantes en nuestra clase asignar 3
recursos por semana durante lo que dure
el campeonato revisar el tablero de
progreso y celebrar el logro de los
alumnos hay que motivar a los chicos ok
que es importante también que eliminemos
las clases inactivas hay muy bien muchas
gracias
miren la profesora marta es más
ambiciosa 5 tareas a la semana perfecto
mis marta tizimín nómina de por acá
perfecto
muy bien ok y ahora para los alumnos qué
debemos hacer para que nuestros alumnos
tengan éxito en el campeonato
qué porcentaje tienen que completar de
ejercicios los alumnos para para poder
ser exitosos en el campeonato
a ver quién me ayuda
aquí es bien importante y tenemos que
trabajar con ellos
de manera colaborativa en equipo porque
tienen que cumplir el cien por ciento
exacto mis lilia muchas gracias de que
plantel nos nos está escribiendo el 100%
de las actividades para para que pueda
ser exitoso o no y es el 100 por ciento
de las actividades no sólo de un alumno
sino de mínimo nuestros días alumnos ok
tienen que realizar las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento ganar puntos
para que puedan también tener medallas y
hay que revisar periódicamente también
el tablero
perfecto muchas gracias profesora edith
si el 100% exactamente es el 100% de las
actividades ok
otra cosa que es importante para
nosotros es muchos de ustedes por lo que
veo ya están utilizando exacto mis todos
deben de trabajar juntos
en otros países están compartiendo mucho
las experiencias que tienen y nosotros
queremos que méxico no se quede atrás
entonces necesitamos que también ustedes
nos ayuden compartiendo experiencias que
tengan dentro del salón de clase con el
hashtag campeonato para que de esta
manera nosotros podamos compartirlos en
seminarios que tenemos como este con
otros profesores motivarlos a que se
unan al campeonato de canal que a demi a
utilizar la plataforma no gracias
entonces si ustedes están teniendo casos
de éxito dentro de su salón
si pueden compartir nos todo eso en
redes sociales nos va a ayudar muchísimo
a nosotros para motivar a otros
profesores a otros alumnos y también
para sus alumnos
al verse en la red social de can academy
seguramente esto también los va a
motivar mucho a ellos entonces hay una
persona que está encargada de estar
viendo qué materiales están subiendo y
si ustedes nada más ponen ahí hashtag
campeonato nosotros es que podemos
compartir este material no
alguna duda pregunta
es momento todavía están a tiempo de
inscribirse de sacar todas las dudas que
tengan para que puedan participar
nada
como ves christine no tienen ya dudas
todas las personas que están mirando a
este webinar entienden cómo crear sus
frases asignar tarea aquí tenemos
algunas preguntas
podrían hacer una muestra de cómo se
agregan en si las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento por favor
[Música]
y creo que igualmente sería motivante
una estadística comparativa de logros
eso es posible christine no lo creo este
año pero esto es algo a experto
alimentación muy importante para
nosotros
sí
pero pienso que estamos trabajando con
el conadeh por ejemplo para ver lo que
está pasando en cada estado ok
bueno profesor tal vez por este año no
sea posible pero igual el próximo sí sí
podemos hacer algo
de las clases
contenidos ahorita voy a entrar
para hacer una clase nueva y
mentalidad de crecimiento
y les mostramos cómo
voy a salirme de esta y voy a entrar acá
vamos a agregar una clase nueva
y la vamos a llamar
crecimiento
vamos a agregar
no me deja crear que la clase a estallar
que ya tenía una con ese nombre
entonces
aquí
aquí está mi hagas está abajo por viene
en la parte de mentalidad de crecimiento
le damos siguiente y ahorita le voy a
dar salta a la parte de agregar
estudiantes
porque en esta cuenta no tengo yo
estudiante sino entonces aquí ya tengo
yo el código lo que es lo que ustedes
les compartirían
y los alumnos tienen que entrar a khan
academy punto org diagonal join poner el
código de la clase para poder entrar no
es la manera como les decía en un
principio más fácil ya que este si les
mandamos correo electrónico muchas veces
no lo no lo ven
entonces bueno ya ya creamos nuestra
clase vamos a encontrar vídeos artículos
y asignarlos a nuestros estudiantes vale
mentalidad de crecimiento vamos a cargar
la clase y aquí hay diferentes cursos
ustedes eligen el contenido que quieren
agregar a este curso de mentalidad de
crecimiento ahorita se va a refrescar la
la pantalla aquí esta números negativos
multiplicación y división yo quiero
asignar este exponente es radio aquí
ustedes van eligiendo qué contenido
quieren agregar a esta clase ok
pueden asignar los todos pueden asignar
sólo unos cuantos aquí ya depende como
van ustedes avanzando
sí claro todavía pueden agregar alumnos
agregar si ustedes ya tienen una clase
con contenido y les faltó algo lo pueden
hacer todo se puede este ir modificando
entonces aquí yo ya tengo 5 contenidos
seleccionados para mi clase de
mentalidad de crecimiento y le doy
asignas yo no aquí no tengo todavía si
este estudiante es por eso no me deja
asignarlo pero bueno aquí incluso puedo
definir la fecha límite y la hora para
que los alumnos este
puedan recibir estos es esta asignación
quedo este la pregunta contestada
profesora sobre la de cómo agregar más
material de mentalidad de crecimiento
yo espero que sí y si no por favor
hágamelo saber
perfecto gracias mis lilia no sé si
alguien más tenga alguna otra duda o
algo más que quieran que les podamos
mostrar
les voy a poner mientras alguien se
anima a hacernos otra pregunta los
correos también este para que nos puedan
contactar o bien a través de la página
de soporte que les mostraba y que les
compartí hace un momento
voy a compartir la vida de soporte
técnico si en este chat otra vez
[Música]
más preguntas no ya todos están
registrados
ahí están ya los correos y bueno
christina en un momento les va a
compartir nuevamente la liga de soporte
y
perfecto mis gracias
los reconocimientos son los que mandaron
y podemos
sí verdad christine los reconocimientos
son estos
sí exacto pero si estás participando en
el programa de capacitación para los
docentes del conalep y la banque syz van
a recibir reconocimientos como
a través de sus correos también entonces
es otra oportunidad de mostrar qué
estás aprendiendo a colocar la cara me
como docente y pienso que todos deberían
participar en esto también quién está
participando en el programa de
capacitación
podrían compartir si uno en la ducha
el programa de capacitación es el que
mencionamos al principio mami rossi está
todavía se pueden registrar también
al contrario mis lilia le vamos a
agradecer mucho que nos compartan las
experiencias el hashtag se lo volvemos a
poner
ok y tenemos
todos cuatro profesores que están aquí
también en el programa de capacitación
mis letizia dice que ella dejó algunas
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
está bien mis
perfecto también estamos buscando a
docentes y sus alumnos que están
participando en el campeonato entonces
una manera de compartir su historia es a
través de twitter o también podrían
hacerme mandar un correo a nosotros pero
queremos
entrevistar a los docentes que están
participando y teniendo éxito con el
campeonato y khan academy este año
escolar
y me regresé en la pantalla para que
vean las diferentes redes sociales donde
pueden compartir todas las experiencias
que tienen con sus alumnos en facebook
twitter e instagram
ok
muy bien alguna otra pregunta profesores
del campeonato algo más que no les haya
quedado todavía claro
muy bien christina no sé tienes algo más
que decir ya
del campeonato en nuestro nuestra página
de soporte técnico hay una manera de
buscar artículos
tienes que preguntar algo y vas a ver
que hay respuestas entonces voy a
compartir un artículo de creando de
crear y administrar tareas para tu clase
y pienso que va a ayudar a ustedes pero
este sitio de soporte técnico tiene
muchísima información y pienso que todos
los docentes deberían a guardar esta
liga
ok vas a compartir tu pantalla no es que
estoy compartiendo la vida perfect
a ver dicen se le asignan tareas sí
profesor si puede modificarlo como le
dice la profesora lilia si se puede
modificar la fecha
la fecha de entrega sin problema igual
puede agregar más alumnos a la clase
igual puede agregar contenido a la clase
puede hacer todas esas modificaciones
guau mis cuatro grupos de que planteles
profesor profesora no sé
ok
alguna otra pregunta o duda algo más que
nos quieran compartir
del conalep de puebla
seis grupos de cuarenta alumnos muy bien
pues ojalá a todos ustedes puedan
compartir sus experiencias en redes
sociales para que también nosotros
podamos compartir lo que ustedes están
haciendo con con el resto de planteles a
nivel nacional no
muchas felicidades
christina algo más que les quieras
comentar
pero muchísimas gracias por venir
tenemos
el mismo ordenar la misma oportunidad es
tratarle a las 4 am hora de la ciudad
mexica y pues estamos aquí para
apoyarles y muchísimas gracias por venir
este que ustedes tienen mucho trabajo y
es un placer muchísimas gracias y mucho
éxito gracias christine yo también
agradezco su atención y nada más nos
pregunta el profesor pedro si se tienen
que registrar para solicitar un kit
bueno los kits se les dan a aquellos
hasta aquellas clases que hayan
completado más niveles
y bueno que hayan logrado su objetivo
todas las metas que tienen por eso
ustedes ya están registrados ya se tiene
la información
aunque el profesor si hay algunos
tutoriales que no pueden ver le pedimos
por favor que nos escriba a soporte para
poder ver qué es lo que lo que está
pasando hace un momentito pusimos la
liga
ahorita la busco y se la vuelvo a
proporcionar ya sea que nos escriba un
correo o bien pueda visitar la página de
soporte
ok
al contrario gracias a ustedes
cualquier duda o comentario seguimos a
sus órdenes y a las 4 de la tarde como
les decía christine va a haber otra
sesión por si se les ocurre algo en
estos en estas dos horas para poderlos
apoyar muchas gracias
al contrario mis lilia mucha suerte